because of everything that's been going
on in Texas this week, this tragic
mismanagement combined with denial of climate
science and so many other things that have led to
millions of people in Texas
ending up without power.
People in Austin being told to boil
water, which many of them can't do
because they don't have power and they're relying
on either an electric microwave or an electric
oven and stove that they would need to
boil the water. That needs to be boiled
because power is out at the water treatment plant.
So this chaos goes back a long time. We know this
because in 2011, similar power outages happened
in Texas. A report was issued explaining what
Texas needs to do in order to protect themselves
in situations like this. And they didn't do it.
But I want to go back to an interview I did a
few years ago with Gretchen Boki about exactly
the relationship between the electrical grid, a
green alternative, renewable energy, the conflicts
that exist because of business interests
and politics and so many other things. So
could not be a more relevant time to revisit this
interview with Gretchen. Let's get right into it.
I'm joined today by Gretchen Boki, who is author
of The Grid The Fraying Wires Between Americans
and Our Energy Future. Gretchen, it's so great
to talk to you. We talk so much about the move
towards alternative and renewable sources of
energy. We talk about the political implications
and the sort of economic implications. But one
thing that's often missing from that conversation
is sort of the reality of the electrical
grid that we're working with and some of
the limitations that exist. And we'll sort
of have to be dealt with if we really want
to move away from fossil fuels, which I believe
that we should be trying to do. Let's start as
broadly as you want to. I mean, what are some
of the limitations that need to be considered?
Well, I think the main thing that people don't
quite grasp when there's when when when thinking
about the energy transition is that electricity
can't really be stored right now. And what that
means is that as it's made, it's used, it's this
very instantaneous product. So as it's made,
it's used. And that means that if we make it
with something like coal, it's a very steady
production. And if we make it with something
like wind, it's a very unsteady production
because the amount of electricity changes as
the as the rate of the wind blowing changes.
And so that's called variable generation. And
it's the more of it that we put into our grid,
we tend to think of it as renewables. But not
all renewables are variable. And the more we
put of it, we put into the grid, the the harder
it is to manage this sort of perfect balancing
of how much electricity we use in any instant
and how much electricity we produce in that same
instant because electricity is essentially
instantaneous. So almost never more than a
minute between when it's made and when it's used.
And this is particularly relevant for people who
already have or are thinking of moving to solar
power in their home, unless you actually have
a means of storing electricity.
Right. Unless you have an actual
battery set up, any excess electricity
that is harvested by your home solar system
is not stored for your future use, but rather goes
back into the grid and as you mentioned, is almost
instantaneously used by someone else. I mean,
is that generally the way that it works?
Yeah, and I think that's one of the things that
I was really confused about for a long time was
why people could have diesel generators and
seem to be like when there was a blackout,
they would be able to power things in their
house. But if you have solar panels, you can't.
And like many people, I thought that was
something that the utilities were somehow
scheming to make it that you so you couldn't go
off the grid completely. But actually, diesel
generators have all these very heavy pieces inside
of them. And so when you turn on a light switch,
there's a kind of inertial force inside the
generator that allows it to balance your house.
So the the power you have on or turning
on or turning off at any moment,
it has to be balanced by the amount of electricity
that generator is producing. So, again, the
fossil fuel and then this heavy piece of equipment
enable you to run your house even without storage,
whereas solar panels, obviously, you're not going
to have any any power at night. But even so,
you turn on your light. There's no way for for a
solar panel to adjust to that without some kind of
storage. So you turn on a light, you're asking for
more electricity from that system. But that system
is just producing electricity based on how much
sun is hitting it at that moment. And we don't
use we don't even think in terms of like, OK, it's
midday and it's really sunny. So I'm going to run
everything right now. Right. Our fridge turns on,
our freezer turns on, it goes off. We turn on the
lights, we turn them off. And all of that has to
be balanced in some way by something. And right
now that something is the grid and people like the
grid, it's not there's not a there's not really
a strong movement, I think, against the grid. But
there is this sense of like, why can't I be energy
independent? And the reason for that is when you
turn on the light and you have solar panels, that
extra electricity needs to come from somewhere.
So it comes through the grid. And if the grid
is down, then it doesn't it doesn't come from
anywhere and is part of the path forward on this.
I mean, Elon Musk from Tesla has talked about
the home battery systems that they're working on.
That within a few years, he says, will
be relatively affordable. I mean, is
is that the type of solution that you
see is the most likely to this problem?
I think it's very hard to see the future because
I think that people really like the idea of being
part of a larger electricity system. It's it was
very rare in my research that I found people that
wanted to wanted some kind of energy, want it to
be isolated all the time. They're happy to produce
for the grid solar panels in particular, like
very happy to produce for the grid during the
daytime to to draw from the grid at night time.
So I think that that there is a possibility,
certainly with those home battery storage systems,
that you could be energy independent all the time.
So you wouldn't need the grid at all. But I think
what's more likely is that people will start to
use those so that they have power when the power
is out on the larger system. And and that was
a lot of what was happening when I was doing my
research, is that a lot of the frustration I found
with the electricity system, part of it was
this feeling of like we want more renewables,
which is which is very hard to manage. And I think
there's a lot of work going in that direction by
people who do manage the grid right now, but not
fast enough. There's there's a lot of anger with
the utilities in particular for not making that.
And quickly enough, but the other big frustration
was, my power is out all the time, I have solar
panels, why can't I just have my power beyond,
like, why do I have to also have
a diesel backup generator? So
this movement from producing power independently,
but also trying to be green at home and wanting
the larger electricity system to be green as well.
So if we step aside a little bit from the storage
aspect of it, I'd love to talk a little bit
about some of the other ways in which the grid
is relatively susceptible to outside forces.
We have mostly in this country, elevated power
lines where anything from weather to a squirrel
can cause pretty significant interruptions. Is
that one of the biggest sort of liabilities
in the American electrical grid right now?
You mean the the the power
lines being above ground?
Yeah, it's certainly certainly it's it is in part
because the greatest threat to the grid right now
is growing trees. So if they were underground,
that would be less of a problem. It's really hard
to cut back all of the foliage that is just
up and coming over this huge nation. Right.
Is always just going up and up and up and sort of
grabbing at power lines. So, yes, it's not always
the answer to bury, though. If you have someplace
like Florida with a high sort of a high tidal,
I don't know. I think the word is scale,
but the water comes at very high tidally
or when when it's very wet, you don't want to
bury you don't want to bury lines and you don't
even want critical infrastructure at ground level.
You want to start putting stuff up. You want to
put your substations on hills. So for some places,
it's quite it's quite a good idea to bury lines.
In other places, it's a good idea. The grid is
weirdly local. So we have three of them in the
US and they're each gigantic through these huge
machines or sort of one for the west, one for
the east and one for Texas. But nevertheless,
it's also extremely local in how it's designed,
how different states have been keeping it up, the
kinds of laws there are laws that are federal,
but there are many laws that are very particular
to states or even to counties or municipalities.
So taking into account the weather in particular
places matters for answering that question. But
it's also extremely expensive to bury lines.
And that also goes towards what sort of
underlying this, which is I don't know if I would
call it a jurisdictional issue, but certainly one
of ownership, which is that there is not like a
single entity that owns or controls or maintains
the grid. Right. I mean, as you're sort
of talking about, you're talking about
municipalities and a lot of smaller
entities that are part of this grid.
Mm hmm. And even manage their own grid.
There are many municipal like Los Angeles,
for example, has it manages its own grid, even
though that grid is connected into the entire
gigantic grid, which covers the whole of the West.
It's still that particular piece of it, like where
they're buying electricity from, how much they're
paying for it, who's maintaining the lines. All
of that is is managed by the municipality. And
some municipal goods are very, very small. I
talk about in the book Rancho Cucamonga, which has
one streetlight, but they have a municipal power,
municipal power, governance, and people, again,
are sort of organizing suburbs, et cetera, as
they get frustrated with the rate of change to a
more renewable, renewably powered system. They are
they'll just get towns or suburbs together and
they'll they'll aggregate, it's called from the
big grid and take over their own little piece of
it to manage it for themselves. So that's sort of
that's how that happens legally in the state.
So it's both big and very, very small, very,
very local and absolutely nationally gigantic.
And I think that's where you see a lot of the
excitement about what's happening right
now. I know most people don't really see
the grid or think about the grid, but it's it's
changing radically at this exact moment in time.
And lots of people are causing that
change to happen in different ways.
Well, it is a hugely important issue,
particularly when we have the conversation about
when and how will we get off of fossil
fuels. It's something that that could
not be more important. Again, we've been
talking about the book The Grid, the Fraying
Wires Between Americans and Our Energy Future.
And we've been speaking with the book's author,
Gretchen Boki. Thanks so much for talking to
us about that. Yeah, my pleasure. Thank you.